- Thanksgiving is fast
approaching and I wanna know,
will my waistband influence
how much food I can shove in my face?
This is Brendan.
Brendan agreed to eat a Thanksgiving meal,
three days this week.
- How did you get the
bigger lab coat than me?
- Shut up.
Each day he'll be wearing
a waistband with different tightness.
Jeans, sweatpants,
and a dress.
We'll determine if his waistband effects
how much food he can push down his throat.
At each meal, Brendan will
have a cup of stuffing,
a cup of mashed potatoes,
a can of cranberries,
four bread rolls, a whole pumpkin pie,
and a pound of sliced deli turkey meat.
Because markets didn't
have whole cooked turkeys
at the time we shot this.
At the end of the meal,
we'll determine how much food he ate.
And at the end of this experiment,
we'll know with which waistband
he was able to eat the most food.
Let's eat.
- Gobble, gobble.
(lighthearted music)
(sign squeaks)
Normal on Thanksgiving, I go ham.
Well, turkey, I guess.
(drum roll banging)
But I eat as much as I can.
You guys just gonna hang out
and watch me eat for awhile?
All right, easily my favorite things,
Thanksgiving food wise,
of pumpkin pie and the cranberry sauce.
I like the sweet stuff.
So a lot people are very
divided on the cranberry debate.
A lot of people are grossed
out by the jellied kind,
that's just canned shaped.
There are a few things I love more
than a good old can shape
of jellied cranberry sauce.
Barely food, it's delicious.
(upbeat music)
I'm definitely feeling it.
I'm feeling the bloat a little bit.
I still got more room,
I'm not stopping yet.
I feel like my comfort
level would be higher
if I were wearing sweatpants right now.
'Cause I already feel
that unforgiving waistband
of the jeans just cutting
into my rapidly expanding gut.
(belches)
That being said, I'm gonna
eat some of this pie.
Pumpkin pie is my absolute
favorite thing about Thanksgiving.
I also typically just
like to eat the filling
and leave the crust.
It's not weird at all.
Lots of people eat the
filling and not the crust.
This is a documented thing,
there's millions of us.
I'm at that point, that
you have in big meal,
where your brain's like,
"You're done, you're good."
And you're like, "No, I'm fine."
And you keep eating.
I, by any reasonable measure,
should stop eating right now.
But I have no intention
to 'cause it's delicious.
I'm barely even enjoying this pie now.
But I can't stop eating it.
I'm high on pie, I don't know.
Yeah, this stuff's gross.
Oh, I'm gonna call it
actually on that one.
I feel like I did pretty well.
I physically could fit a little more food.
But I am woefully uncomfortable already.
(belches)
I am getting paid today to come to work
in sweatpants and eat a
bunch of Thanksgiving food.
I am free from the clutches of denim.
Strategy today, I'm gonna try
to mix it up a little bit.
Today, I'm gonna hit the
turkey a little harder.
I might eat a roll, I don't know.
I don't want to get ahead of myself.
I feel like sweatpants are like
a magical talisman that you put on
and then you can suddenly
fit more food in your body.
(energetic music)
A luxury, baby.
I already, at this point, haven
eaten quite a bit of food,
feel exponentially more comfortable
than I did in the jeans.
(energetic music)
I think I'm done.
I ate more food but I feel just more,
just kind of like ready for a
nap, as opposed to miserable.
I am super excited to
see how dress day goes
so I will see you tomorrow.
I have never worn a dress before.
Turns out they are
luxuriously comfortable.
I feel like this is
gonna blow the sweatpants
and definitely the jeans out of the water.
But America, we gotta adopt
more dresses for dudes.
This is fantastic.
Today, no strategy.
My only strategy is I'm gonna eat
all of the food I can and see
where this dress takes me.
♪ Turkey time ♪
Well, it turns out Thanksgiving
food, still delicious.
I'm very thankful, obviously,
for friends and family and loved ones
and all of the important stuff.
But this year, I'm mostly
thankful for this dress.
I'm gonna hit the bread, I'm
gonna hit the bread early.
I haven't hit the bread this early
in either of the other meals.
Why am I hitting it so early?
Dress.
(gentle music)
Compared to the last two days,
at this point in the meal,
I feel way better than
I felt the other two.
The first two days--
Yeah, even in the sweatpants,
I still felt that bloat coming in,
that tightness around the waist.
I don't feel that at all right now.
I feel like I'm eating naked,
which would be another cool thing to try.
This is seriously fantastic.
I feel like I could accomplish
anything in this dress.
Is this what women feel like all the time?
(upbeat music)
Pie is good, but again,
it's not as good as my mom's pumpkin pie.
Shout out to my mom.
(upbeat music)
So today in the dress,
I was able to eat all
of the mashed potatoes,
all the stuffing, half the turkey,
about three quarters of
the can of cranberry sauce,
and probably about a little
over a quarter of the pie.
I do feel like I ate the most
amount of food in the dress
and was still the most comfortable
out of the three outfits.
- After calculating our numbers,
and taking Brendan's comfort
level into consideration,
the winner of the waistband
Thanksgiving experiment
is the dress.
(audience cheers)
Brendan, how do these results
compare with your experience?
- The dress made a huge difference.
Not just in how much I was able to eat,
but also how comfortable
I was while eating.
- There you have it, folks.
Wear whatever the hell
you want to Thanksgiving.
You're just gonna shove
your face full of food regardless.
- But wear a dress,
definitely, wear a dress.
(upbeat music)
(sign squeaks)